thank you Yasser Hans welcome back to
the show how's uh the last week been for
you
just playing chess
and how how is the chess going
well not that well but it could be worse
absolutely and today you kind of pulled
the brakes early on can you talk to us
about today's game a little bit yeah
well we can start uh at the small rookie
too
so I was a bit surprised by this queen
B8 Queen A7 stuff and uh there was a
game due to the candidates
so I of course after Queen instead of
rookie two there's D4 and it's long
stuff but the
I had not checked this before the game
so I did not think it would be wise to
go into such a forcing line without
let's say direct concrete knowledge so
you were playing fast after this yeah
but usually if you're going to do
something in this D4 line you need
something extremely direct and uh I just
didn't check it before the game so
I remember checking rookie too because
it was played in the candidates A4
um yeah Knight G3 Queen A5 to take and
you were playing really fast yeah so I
remember this you're in your book well
um I think I remember
um here was where my concrete knowledge
ended
um I was just really struggling to think
remember but from what I analyzed I sort
of felt like um you can play this in a
very slow way a capture Queen C2 maybe
it was what I checked yeah
um Queen B5 C4 Queen be at this I sort
of vaguely remembered
um and I think in this position of
course it's equal but
um there's not a lot of risk for weight
because you sort of have control
um over the major Palm bricks you know
if black isn't really going to play D
hover F5 then you're sort of maintaining
control and you always have Bishop B2 or
Rook B1 B4 and then there's you know I
remember checking you know the main
ideas of King H2 Knight H4 not a five so
I remember the ideas vaguely
um
but I think this queen B5 couldn't be it
is actually quite precise
um how the Geo says the position right
now and did you talk to your opponent
after the game did you guys discovered
he didn't he didn't know I think in the
game I don't know if I don't really
remember the precise of The Duda uh ding
game but I think it was something like a
bishop B6 if you want to go back
instead of uh I think he played five
queen Queen Bishop B6 some some I don't
remember basically it went like Bishop
B6 Queen A6
um some that's what these are and
that's all I remember
um but anyways in the game I think the
critical moment is I played this move
not H4
um yeah allowing D5 which is just quite
stupid
um I just completely forgot that it was
possible so that was just a very Hasty
mistake um but instead of Knight H4 I
should play Bishop C3 uh just sort of
stopping that how Wild Bishop before
okay
so I guess I have to already play uh and
let's say not Bishop C3
number should be 4K so that I guess I
have to go B4 already before yeah this
is yeah before take take uh I didn't
like Bishop before yeah um but yeah I
saw D4 here but I wasn't sure how to
evaluate this
um stero seems very yeah so let's say
after a b he goes Bishop B6 yeah I saw
this and then I go B4
um yeah Queen d8 Bishop C3
so what is black trying to do yeah it's
a very weird position on Queen A5 Queen
B5 Queen B yeah it's a very very weird
position
um from what I remember you're just
white it has a grip and I didn't feel
that natural for me to play for black to
play when I was analyzing this but you
know I was checking this back when the
candidates was happening so the
knowledge wasn't too fresh but yeah
after you played uh D5 I was like okay
it's time to make a draw I was trying to
learn from my past transgressions of
over pushing with white
um so okay another three is that a
difficult thing to do yeah right yeah
you sort of have to just sort of you
know swallow your pride and yeah admit
your mistake
um so I think my past games are
certainly conditioned me to to make that
decision much easier
because I guess it's tempting to go oh
to claim oh yeah you know I didn't make
a mistake notified yeah and then you're
like pushed by faith in your weight oh
wait was my knight doing an F5 and then
and then things you know you know it's
important when things to adjust your
mindset uh I've learned that from my
previous games it's very important to
adjust your mindset
um because I think your perception of
the position
has quite a significant impact on how
you play because for example I think
that if you had the ability to tell
yourself that you were playing a
different color I think that that's that
if you could do that as a chess player I
think that would like you know plus 50
rating points like in so many of my
games this tournament if I could just be
like no no you have black here it's time
to defend I would just make it draw like
very easily
um so I I think you started with white
you started with yeah and then you have
white and it just trust is more
psychological Than People realize so
that's something that I I think I
learned from my my two or two losses
with white uh they're completely
uncalled for absolutely and uh yeah so
he okay he repeated I was very happy to
see this yeah you were okay
I was like come on when you play 92.3
you're ready you're ready for the game
to be over
and uh I I also felt like this and how a
tournament was going he wasn't
in such a fighting mode as well okay I'm
seeing that after Bishop wait after
Bishop B5 I have I can Bishop no instead
of Bishop B2 I could have played
uh Knight to five here you mean
interesting yeah okay but okay I I think
it was I think it was time to just uh
call it the day cold today yeah because
actually um in my game against Wesley in
Singapore cup I was told just to make a
draw you can go today and I was very
adamantly told this
um and I didn't listen and we should
happen so I think uh I was very much
in a crisis control mode and uh I think
that that's very important so I think uh
Beyond I think the way to improve my
chest is just to um become colorblind
and wear some special glasses that make
me can't see color and then if I cannot
if I don't know if I'm white or black
then I think my chest will improve
drastically uh since we last talked any
ubereats Adventures for you
and uh it took like an hour then they
canceled it so that was unfortunately I
might have to switch to another app
um because ubereats has let me down I
haven't used it just because
when you order something and you're
waiting for it for like half an hour and
then
you watch the the driver like go in
circles
and then they and then they manage the
driver and then they cancel it you sort
of just uh revert back to actually going
outside and walking to get food so yeah
I don't know I think it reads uh has
lost my business and how about the
Berlin defense did you analyze that
during the rest day did you find
anything new share we share it with us
no no I am
no nothing nothing to share
guys any questions uh just a quick one
uh Hans
um I don't know if you paid attention to
the game of a Wonder Liang and if you
saw Knight takes E4 uh if it if that if
if you saw it and if if it caused you to
smile this rookie rookie mistake I
really don't want to you know let's I'm
actually familiar with this and it's
actually not as bad as it looks and I
actually have very very um specific
childhood memory of this game and I had
a game
in this position and I play Queen E2 and
this was in the Netherlands and I
remember this is like any point out of
six and I was like a kid
and they might not have sex and I
remember this it's like it's so insane
that I remember this and I was playing
the tournament and I went 96 and I
looked at the kid and I was like
and I also remember you know I've always
been a quite an opening this was an
opening novelty but I'd also like to
point out and this exact same tournament
I don't know why I remember this I had a
game e45
Queen H5 and I came up with a move
Knight F6 you know uh you know
eight-year-old me
so I remember this exact tournament I
had two identical games and I won a
beautiful game so you guys just brought
back some Childish memories
um is this supposed to be a good movie
it's Knight F6 well uh eight-year-old me
came up with it and was like I'm a
genius
it says no games
and that is exactly you know why I'm
hungry
but I remember this exact same
tournament it was like one of my like if
my first you know tournament where I won
a trophy and I remember two games you
know Knight of six Knight C6 906 Queen
E5 and uh so you guys have but it's
actually not that bad there's a someone
made a trustable course on this um I
don't remember
maybe Anish no no no um but there's a
principal course on this and actually
checked it out and like uh I think the
trapism if you go to the game the Trap
is like there's some like uh so desync
no 94 22 D6 uh D4 tick tick uh Knight
six and like if Bishop by four there's
like G5 right this is like the Trap
right yeah yeah this is yeah and some
weird stuff yeah okay I Wonder has has
been quite creative uh I think you have
to get creative you know if you're you
know slaving away to Ivy League so or
university you know you have to get
creative because you're just being you
know all your time is being sucked away
by academic boredom so
um but yeah I know this is actually a
very interesting choice I think I was
very impressed but it doesn't seem to be
working well but uh I respect the uh the
creativity Hans thank you very much
at times uh nice that we all have these
childhood memories of Knight C6 check
and winning the queen and uh